hey guys sometimes I think the meta of
the situation is far more powerful than
what one can see right I think it's far
more fascinating that the process of
trying to buy the New York Jets is far
more cool than when I'm an old man
holding up like I did it
the chef's prep not the dish we get to
kind of uncover that for you here in the
way that I think about content the way I
interact with my team many of you are
now building out teams and I think the
insight in this article this video this
piece of content is going to really
teach something because it taught us
something and I'm really excited about
sharing it with you please enjoy this I
think you'll get it once you consume it
chances are good that you've heard that
way more Instagram recently launched
IPTV a new long-form video up app where
creators can upload content can you
change the love attention to I respect
and value attention yes because love
attempt you know what I mean doesn't
teach it doesn't tree like an app an
asset it treats it like I love attention
yeah which I do let's not get confused
around here I like I'm both vlog all
forms some attention are delicious good
without their attention so I stay on top
of my craft by keeping up to date with
all of the changes on virtually any
platform where I think there's an
abundance of attention especially if I
think it's under priced if you haven't
heard Instagram just launched a mobile
centric long-form video platform called
the IG TV Instagram television
I can keep these as a standalone app
that has a discovery fee to integrated
into Instagram this basically means what
happens in the standalone app can you do
anything there that you can't do within
Instagram Thanks links so people are
following people only on IG TV or when
you go into it let me look at it because
I've really been like I actually am so
down on what they did so far like it
could be a monster but what I wanted is
not what they did which was just long
for him Instagram video post like they
went they went all the way in a
different way you don't know you still
don't you know you don't have this
little thing up there no but if I like
interesting now you don't you know that
I'm like the only person ever that
doesn't have reddit cop you know I still
don't have comments you don't I don't
have comments what do I mean this is had
my comments like still
they're really trying to hold you better
the gram is holding me back but yeah but
if I switch an account it has what I was
gonna see the other thing that's really
interested the IG TV is so where's the
links in there there's links in here
somewhere
[Music]
are we posting on IG TV a little bit we
did just today we started where the
daily video will play out on a GTV
[Music]
that is human that's how crazy it
surface but we also loved here wack
[Music]
okay go into an explorer section and
find content curated for you by the IDT
be algorithm based on your interests and
people you follow which will then take
you to the IG TV app as i see it i PT p
is trying to capture the end users
attention through its analysis of
growing and entertainment trends which
that which is that over the past 100
years we've seen a massive shift in the
way that we consume contents in today's
world almost everything we consume is
mobile the shift of attention it has
become so obvious that in instagrams
announcement for id TV they said that
teens are watching 40% less TV than they
did five years ago
I'm sure that many of you know how much
what is it 40% less I think that's by
the way mention I think that's
underrated I don't know how Facebook and
Instagram got its data
I think that's low teens don't [ __ ]
watch TV bro like I understand that
they're trying to be nice control of
society so it probably isn't much of a
surprise when I say that this is most
likely going to be looked at as a very
smart move by Instagram I say this
because one Instagram line outside ETV
they also revealed that Instagram
currently has one
billion monthly active users with this
in mind Instagram is effectively
Instagram effectively has the ability to
cross pollinate 1 billion monthly active
users on by GTV which then allows IPTV
to give other long-form video such as
the YouTube mobile apps a pretty serious
run for their money with regards to the
launch by DTV I think that it's
important to include the IDT be
partnered with a few massive influencers
such as ninja and KZ HD and Philip
DeFranco discrete contents during the
launch of the apps I don't think that
most people will realize how big of a
deal this is influencers are a strong
source of underpriced attention which is
why I think that is good I'm awfully
confused right now
yes where's IG TV in the top free apps
was it there touring the beginning press
more like this I can figure it out
yeah the problem with this article right
now is I think you guys made it yeah
you've made assumptions like I'm weirdly
not like one of the reasons I don't want
to have it yeah no exactly what you're
saying there's an app called body
slimmer but that's why everyone's so
attractive on Instagram
but then I think it all goes like me not
having it on my phone how they wrote it
out I think is how they've done they're
just like going small on mic learning
how people interacted then now and maybe
there's an update no money now that
makes more impact I think a lot of
people have no idea that I do TV even
exists
yeah I'm not so sure I want to write
this article no cuz I don't have an
opinion yet my opinion on IG TV is okay
like you know it's here
great I'm not in the prediction business
like I wasn't excited about giving my
prediction on on vero or peach or all
this others like I'm not the guy you go
to in the first like I've only been
wrong when I try to come up with an
opinion in the first twenty five like
this should be the article why I don't
talk about well actually here's the
article why I haven't come out on
Instagram TV yet I'm being serious right
now
that's a good article yeah why did I
even have an article ready because
having an article in an opinion the
moment it pops is good for SEO and good
for like people getting a quick read big
problem for me is I should have known
better like I [ __ ] don't like
guessing like well I'm at my best you
know three months in like it's why I
don't believe in hiring like it's like
rare like you know like that's what I
equate it to like a hoot like
everybody's running out like the meat
personalities in punt I'm not a
personality abundant I'm not a [ __ ]
pundit Calvin
I'm not a pundit dude like I don't I
don't give a [ __ ] if I have an opinion
but like everybody runs out and declared
peach the next big thing yeah I'm right
a lot after I'm thoughtful after it's
obvious like there's nothing obvious
about IG TV yet like here's what's
obvious that was weird
it's not exactly how I saw it coming I
thought it was gonna be long-form video
in IG which would have crushed still
believe that instead they went this
route which is a complete attack on
YouTube makes sense because Obama
Instagram coming after a very successful
attack on snapchat what's going on in
[ __ ] Instagram headquarters this be
like bucket YouTube's not that mobile
YouTube is not mobile let's not forget
the Facebook let Twitter grow because
Facebook wasn't mobile Facebook was
desktop sucks was slowish came in hard
and did his thing
they were slow ish they're probably
sitting around and saying huh you know
what you total product is not that great
I write why I was talking about tumblr
should have one but they didn't go to
mobile I would be in YouTube a lot more
in comments if it was more mobile like
I'm not in YouTube we're not winning on
YouTube as much mainly on the back that
YouTube is not a disproportionately
awesome mobile experience and I don't
[ __ ] own a computer for three years
by the way the whole vertical horizontal
like if the next like if I'm starting a
startup right now I'm going horizontal
like if I'm sitting in [ __ ] Silicon
Valley right now I'm coming out with a
horizontal social network what how hard
was that if it's [ __ ] fighter like
everybody's got that [ __ ] [ __ ]
back here anyway every [ __ ] teenagers
fell for that [ __ ] [ __ ] like if
you don't have a lot of [ __ ] little
circle here or your [ __ ] wallet here
you're [ __ ] it you're [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] this is a much better article
than what you're trying to fabricate
right now I'm coming out with real good
value why don't we just post on LinkedIn
like yo we were gonna write this article
but you know what [ __ ] it
just watch this entire video starts with
a little reading just shows everything
like this is what this is this real this
is them
they should definitely be the podcast
you know podcasts what's up hope you
enjoying this [ __ ] epic episode
please hit me up on Twitter Gary Vee can
we just make a post by the way I need a
LinkedIn post right now about like yo
I'm really active on [ __ ] Twitter let
me just write that real quick like can
we get a nice piece of content like like
the written word like can we do a
written one and an image one and maybe
even this video clip okay good why we're
behind if it's Twitter soccer he wants
to be involved or sneakers so what
that's it right like [ __ ] IG TV right
now because I'm not ready to [ __ ] say
anything yet and I'm watching and guess
what so far I'm not feeling it in the
culture I don't hear anybody like yo now
on the flip side that's probably like
like it's probably underpriced attention
like let's talk about another thing IG
wants it to [ __ ] work so here's a
[ __ ] point of view if you're making
if you're making a GTV videos
you're probably gonna do okay because
they really give a [ __ ] like you know
they're gonna they're gonna do it have a
[ __ ] they can to make that work they
went right after YouTube but they went
after YouTube very specifically like
[ __ ] it let's just take YouTube right
let's just take it instead of what I
think is actually smarter which would
have been just like make long-form
videos in instant
and it would have just taken YouTube
like I could see so many bloggers being
like [ __ ] it you know a vlog here and so
what's the modification I think I gdb
they got ads yeah well that's because
most people are short term and not smart
[Music]
accepted by the masses because Drake and
then joined got together on discord
industry and fortnight now if you've
been pretty deep into my content over
the past three years you'll know that
this to become at any surprise to me I
knew that a crossover moment where
twitch eSports
we even have those links right there
like like literally right love this
document [ __ ] I really want to bring the
askgaryvee show back
[Music]